foreign
let's go to Ryan
man all the way to Fairbanks Alaska
what's up Ryan
hey John how are you doing I'm good man
how's uh how's things
oh they've been better but I can't
complain too much I'm pretty blessed so
tell me what's going on man how can I
help
so I am now in my third week of me and
my wife being separated for the second
time and
I guess where my mind is going on this
is I'm starting to feel a disconnect
kind of like my body's telling me or
preparing me for
more drama and I'm just in this mindset
of what where did I go from here I do
want to save this marriage but I'm at
the same time I'm just starting to feel
disconnected and I'm kind of lost here
man yeah dude so what happened man why
are y'all separated again
run me through the first one in 30
seconds or less and then give me the
second one all right first time
um came back from Afghanistan 2012
became an alcoholic or a weekend
alcoholic and eight years later of being
an alcoholic just trying to kicked me
out okay
um second time I sobered up
for October 24 2020 so I've been sober
since then
um
well I appreciate it um this time is I
didn't have it all together financially
and I wasn't sticking to the AAA
meetings that she asked me to do okay
and there's a lot that goes behind that
but
so normally it's not the alcohol
normally it's the person
the person it's the person you become
when you're drinking so who are you when
you drink
uh disconnected
um emotionally absent
uh
didn't
give her anything that she needed in a
marriage when I was drinking I was just
separate like roommates go to bed late
never never present
so you weren't you're not violent you're
not rageful
no sir okay so instead of big outbursts
you just slowly over the course of a
decade
um
she just
she just slowly was drowning right
right and isolation she said what was it
what was there some big event or she
finally just had enough and and back in
20. she has stuck around and really
supported me through the last eight
years and I think she just had enough
you know enough's enough and it was
unhealthy and it was time to make a
change so what brought you back together
well I believe sobriety had a big play
in that I you know I stayed sober for
you know the last 20 22 months and you
picked a hell of a time to get sober man
congratulations it's been a hard season
dude if you can get through this season
wow
um
when you got sober
what
did you heal or do you trade
here's what I mean by that
you come back from Afghanistan
you experience some stuff you saw some
stuff drinking helps that mute that
alarm system right it works and then you
can go work during the week and stay
busy and that helps and then you can
collapse in the evening and do the whole
thing up over again
and
then you can go through treatment and
you can go to AAA or whatever get sober
you can stop putting alcohol in your
body
but if you don't go through the process
of healing what your body was trying to
numb out in the first place
then it just moves to something else
and sometimes that's something else is
work sometimes that something else is
Netflix sometimes that something else is
just staring off into space
did you heal or did you just trade
addictions
I believe I traded addiction for work
okay I'm being honest there was
something appreciate your bravery yeah
yeah I believe I did I work a lot and
there are some other things going on I
was looking down the barrel of the
divorce shotgun there and
and it didn't happen thank God but it
was there's just a lot of going on and I
was focusing heavily on what she was
doing instead of what I needed to do to
Hill that's right
so it sounds like she got back into a
relationship with you because alcohol
was gone and she married the same or she
got back connected with the same person
who showed up and would just unplugged
just instead of
um sleeping with alcohol now you started
sleeping with your job is that fair yep
okay that's fair so
the hard question I always ask in the
situation is is she interested in
staying married
um
then I don't believe she is okay that's
been brought up and the last separation
that was brought up and I was told I
would have paperwork at the end of the
next week and that was 2020. so we're
looking at 2022. I'm not sure honestly
you know if she could pull the trigger
any point or not
so what do you want to do man
foreign
[Music]
personally I want to say the marriage
and there's a lot here we have five kids
together we have a big family and
I believe we can build something yeah I
truly do yeah but I'm trying to get
healed myself yeah at the same time has
she told you
what she needs from you
I believe I've heard her say this I want
to say yes but there's I feel like I'm
missing information and we just never
connect on that level of what do you
truly need for me and not what are you
asking for me have you gone to see a
marriage counselor uh no why not charge
I tried to get her in with one of my
counselors and it didn't go very well
and I do have it I do have a marriage
counselor and a trauma counselor
scheduled for the end of this month okay
so that's on the table but I man she
just she feels done she really doesn't
want to be here
so here's here's what you can do right
now
um
you can look at this as a mission to
quote unquote save this marriage
and if you look back over the last 10
years
what you're going to end up doing is
trying to solve a puzzle
um that you don't have all the pieces
too
and so you're going to end up using a
lot of energy you're going to have a lot
of worry you're gonna have a lot of
expense you can do a lot of stuff that
may not get you where you want to go
you have been a brave man to say the
words that when you look in the mirror
and you're honest
most of this challenges you
for any number of reasons it might be on
dealt with childhood trauma it might be
stuff you dealt with on Mission it on
deployment who knows what it is it might
be you got home and you got five kids
and you feel like you're better at work
than you are at home and so we naturally
just gonna go where we do things that
we're better right I've been there
all that to say is you've landed here
and a common denominator moving forward
is you you haven't told me anything that
she's cheating on you that she's an
addict too that you just said like no
she's just been putting in the time and
putting in the time and finally she just
said I can't I'm I'm out is that is that
fair
yeah I mean there was some infidelity
that caused some trauma on her part she
cheated on you yes okay all right so
she's not blame us in this deal either
right neither one of us are okay all
right
so there's two things moving forward man
one is you coming up with a clear
detailed plan
on how Ryan's life is going to be
different
not how your marriage is going to get
saved not how your wife's and you are
gonna
how Ryan's life is going to be different
and the cool thing about that is or the
sucky thing is is you play a role in it
the cool thing is you can work on that
and that might be as simple as I'm going
to turn the TV off I'm gonna start
getting some sleep I'm gonna start
getting some exercise I'm gonna get a
group of guys together I'm gonna go see
a therapist ASAP
those are all things that are going to
help you become a better husband a
better father a better employee a better
man a better citizen
it may be that part of who I want to
become is I want to become solvent
financially I'm gonna get out of debt
and stop being an idiot with my money
I'm going to learn new things and then
I'm going to implement these new things
and so it's just a matter of getting on
a plan right hang on the line and I'll
I'm going to put you on a plan for free
I'll pay for it okay
um it may be I'm gonna get a group of
books and I'm gonna get a group of guys
we're gonna start reading books and I'm
gonna I want you to stand alone I'm
gonna send you a couple books you can
read too okay all these things have one
common denominator and that is you
focusing on you getting well for the
first time in a long time hear what I'm
saying
yes sir second thing is this
um you may have heard me say this on the
show it's my favorite marriage metaphor
when you get to these moments
what is in the past
is in the past and there's a period at
the end of that sentence
where most of us who try to fix our
marriages or improve our marriages or
save our marriages and I've been there
is what we try to do is go back to
remember when we didn't have any kids
and how awesome it was we having sex all
the time and we had money to spend and
we were running around the country and
around the world
and we have that picture in our head and
then we try to superimpose that picture
over five kids infidelity alcoholism and
we try to make that work again
and what we have to do is let that go
and so the analogy is you could not go
down to
downtown New York and sweep up all the
glass and twisted steel and recapture
all the natural gas Enrique and and get
all the drywall back and rebuild the
Twin Towers you can't do it now things
look they fell there's a period at the
end of that sentence as hard as that is
to say out loud the only thing we can do
moving forward
is you get some crews in there to
excavate the whole thing get with an
architect or a couple of Architects draw
something new what do we want this thing
to look like get with a set of Engineers
and some construction teams to build
something that's arguably more beautiful
and stronger
and build something completely new
that's the only option you have
or just to move on and let it decay
right so the question for you and your
wife is not hey we want to fix the
marriage and say that it is
I'm interested in building something
completely and totally new
are you in
and that's the limbo right now is
killing you the limbo right now is
killing her and quite honestly the limbo
right now is killing your kids
yeah I think it's time for a breakfast
after you detail all the things you're
going to do and you put the plan down
is to say hey
Do you want to build something new what
was it was Do you want to build
something new with me because if you do
I'm all in
and if not we need to do the paperwork
now and we need to move on
is that fair
yes sir um sorry those are here it's
what I needed do you do you were you in
a combat
yes sir okay you know the difference
between
when the sirens sound and that gap
before confrontation that's the worst
part right
yep it is that's where you are and
that's where you've been for a while
there is no engagement but you know
something's coming and what may be
coming may be
um reconnection and revisiting and
rebuilding Something Magic something
great or it may be the end it may be
termination
but you're in that Gap the sirens are
sounding and they have been for a long
time and there's just no bullets flying
yet and at some point somebody's got to
pull a trigger and I'm kind of beating
this metaphor up but at some point you
got to sit down and y'all go to IHOP
down the street or wherever you go in
Fairbanks Alaska and say
um I don't know if you get a moose
burger or something I don't know but you
go sit down
of course you do be incredible somebody
listening to this send me some moose
meat man I'm all in
um but you go sit down and say hey use
that same metaphor I just gave you we
can't you can't go rebuild 911 the Twin
Towers they fell are you in to build
something new and if you're not let's
call it is as hard as that is Let's Be
adults about this and let's love and
honor these five kids through this or
let's start from ground zero and get the
professionals around us that we need to
build something beautiful are you in on
that
um all right here's what I'm going to
send you to help you get going either
way
I'm going to send you a Year's
subscription to Ramsay plus that's my
friend Dave Ramsey he's got that
Financial Peace University it's millions
and millions of people have used it to
get out of debt I'm gonna send it to you
also comes with the apps and that
connects to your bank and all the stuff
all the bells and whistles okay
I want you to use that thing and I want
you to watch all the videos on that deal
and if she'll watch them with you
that'll be amazing okay that's number
one and make your kids watch them too
why not number two I'm gonna send you my
new book which is own your past change
your future and what that book is is
here's all the stuff
and now we're at the Turning Point
here's all the crap
now we have to ask ourselves that one
terrifying question what do we do now
and it is a step-by-step to walk
yourself out of a Wellness Plan okay I'm
gonna send you that I'm also going to
send you a Total Money Makeover which is
Dave's book that helps with that okay
and I want you to commit to reading
those books let your wife know as a part
of your plan moving forward you're going
to read those books okay so hang on the
line here brother
um I let me just ask are you all in
I'm all in okay thank you okay
let me know how this conversation goes
and by the way if she won't have this
conversation she won't have breakfast
with you
I want you to sit down at a computer
and type out a long letter to her that
explains all this in it she may not give
you an audience now hopefully she does
hopefully she'll be an adult and you can
be an adult and y'all can just go have
breakfast together if she won't ride it
out write her a letter and say Here's
where I'm at here's the things I'm gonna
do here's that picture of the Twin
Towers and here's what I want to do
moving forward
we gotta scratch and clear the surface
and build something brand stinking new
you deserve that she deserves that those
five kids deserve that and I'm here to
tell you I've seen it done
it's a lot of work man
but I was in New York a few weeks ago
doing media
and the monument they've built and the
new tower they've built is something to
behold it can be done
y'all are worth it go get it